>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> We're going to start things out
with structured data story time
from Rachel Shorey who
is a Software Engineer
in the interactive news
department at the New York Times.
She works primarily on large data
collection projects in the newsroom.
Take it away, Rachel.
>> Rachel Shorey: Hi.
My name is Rachel Shorey.
I'm a software engineer
at the New York Times
on the interactive news team, and
I'm going to tell you some stories.
First, I want to talk a little bit
about the interactive
news team at the Times.
We work on a variety of projects,
but we often end up being pulled
in when reporters get stuck
trying to deal with a data problem
or get a full understanding
of a data collection.
We pitch in when data is hard to get
or when there's just too much of it
for a reporter to deal with.
We pitch in when the
form is unusable,
and we pitch in when there's just,
when it's not even totally
clear where the dataset is.
So, I'm here to tell you a
little bit about the story,
the data story behind the story that
you might see in the New York Times.
This is a kind of thing that
happens when you get programmers
in the newsroom collaborating
with reporters.
First, I want to tell you a
little bit more about the,
how the interactive
news team or my part
of the interactive news
team works and collaborates.
One dataset that we've done a
lot of work on is election data.
And, when I tell people that,
they say that's so great.
I love the New York
Times election coverage.
I especially love those
maps and graphics.
And, I say, great.
Me, too. Those are somebody else.
It is a great data project, and I,
we do in some ways contribute to it.
If you imagine those as, like,
a really nice restaurant kitchen
or something like that with like the
fancy dishwasher and the fancy sink
with the, like, hose that you
can wiggle around and the,
and maybe one of those refrigerators
that has the cold water pump all
hooked into the water system.
They're like, that's great.
You're like the plumbing.
And, I'm like.
No. Really, we're more
like the thing
that connects the whole restaurant
to the city's water main.
We're really far back there, but if
it breaks, you really know about it
because there's water everywhere.
So, that's how I think
of some of the work we do
on the interactive team, but I think
the best way to talk about that is
to show it through the way that
these stories come together.
So, here's a story.
Once upon a time, there was
a troublesome web interface.
Here's an example of a web
interface that caused one
of our reporters some trouble.
This is the Bureau of Prisons,
and they make a website
that makes it easy to find an
inmate who is in the federal system.
Unfortunately, if you want
to find an inmate, or well,
I would say fortunately, actually,
because there's some
privacy protection in here.
You can't just type in an age
and find any inmate of that age.
You have to know the person's name.
You have to know some
information about them.
So, in order to do this, you
have to know that information,
and here's an example of
how a search might work.
This is an inmate you
may have heard of.
[ Laughter ]
As I said, to search for a person,
you have to enter their first
and last name, and it won't work
unless those names are correct.
And, if you want to find a lot
of people, you're going to have
to enter them one at a time.
A reporter came to me with a
large number of individuals
that she wanted to look up.
She wanted to look them up because
they were convicted of terrorism
in U.S. courts, and she wanted
to know where they were located.
This was a big deal not too long ago
because there was a lot of question
about whether people in
Guantanamo could be tried or held
in the United States or in
the continental United States.
So, she wasn't quite
sure what to do.
She had all of these people
she wanted to look up.
There were a lot of them, and it
was going to take a long time.
And, to make matters worse, many
of them had three or four names,
and it wasn't quite
clear how they divided
into first, middle, and last name.
So, thankfully, she
had the good sense
to apply a little software
notary to this problem
which she did basically
by turning around.
I happen to sit right
behind this person,
so it was a very easy request.
She said, "Rachel, I need some help.
How are we going to figure this,
get this data out of this website?
I know the data's there.
I just need to get it."
Thankfully, the back end of
that website looks like this.
Anybody who has a little
bit of familiarity poking
around the back ends of websites
will probably have a warm feeling
in their heart about how nice and
easy it is for a software developer
to pull down data like this
to process it and turn it
into usable records that
the reporter can use.
I started working on this.
She returned to calling
government offices
and asking them for
comment on things.
Everyone worked on
what they did best.
We ended up turning this into a
story that also included this map.
We found out where the people
who were convicted of terrorism
in United States courts
are being held.
Indeed, in the United States,
and wrote an accompanying
story about it.
So, using the information
that we were able to gather
as a collaboration between
a reporter and somebody,
a software engineer who
works on data things.
We were able to tell a story
that countered the narrative
that was generally
being told at the time.
I have another example.
I really like this one.
Another example.
A doctor testified in court,
but his name was redacted.
Some of his biographical
details were available, though,
including his data of birth, or his
date and place of certification.
Sorry. Not date of birth.
And some additional
biographical information.
And, a reporter discovered
that there's this search
functionality available
for the American Board of
Psychiatry and Neurology
that lets you determine who
was certified or recertified
at a certain, in a certain
place and at a certain time.
He knew, as I said,
the month and year
of the certification this
individual, but nothing else.
If you look at this web
interface, you might note that date
of certification is not an option.
What he really wanted
was to search by date.
So, he's stuck, at this point.
Thankfully, he knew the phone
number of some local software nerds.
This actually did happen late at
night, so he did call someone.
This call did not go to me.
It went to my colleague
Jeremy Bowers who was supposed
to be here today but
unfortunately could not join us.
So, what Jeremy was able to
do is pull out all of the data
from the database and then do
the search by, and then give it
to the reporter in this format where
he could search and sort by date.
There are about 900
people who match the date
that the reporter was interested in.
He, what he did at that point, the
reporter is he started googling.
He actually googled 88 of
these people, and then,
he found somebody who,
based on other information
that was available online, matched
other biographical information
in the testimony that he had read.
So, yes. After doing this googling,
the reporting team sent somebody
to the house of this doctor,
knocked on his door, and they asked
for an interview, and they got
an hour on the record with him.
This is really a story
that could not have come
about without true
reporter/programmer collaboration.
We didn't have the idea to go
and pull data off that website,
and we didn't have the ability to
go and knock on the door and ask.
I'm a software engineer.
Can you imagine me
knocking on your door?
I'd probably be like, "Um.
Hi. Uh. I'm with the New York Times,
and I'd like to ask
you some questions,"
and it probably wouldn't
have gone well.
So, so, it was really
a great collaboration.
Here's the story that resulted.
It was actually part of a five-part
series about, about medical
and psychiatric care at Guantanamo
Bay, and this is a case where,
if you look at this story,
you would have no idea
that a software engineer or any kind
of data component may have been
involved because there's no graphic.
There's nothing that
looks like data to you,
but the data component was really
important in the reporting.
It's how we found the source,
and it's how we told the story.
Yeah. So, I'm going to
tell you another story.
This is a story about data
that is too big for a reporter.
Once upon a time, the data
just kept coming and coming.
This is a lot of data.
If you are, if you fiddle
around with data a lot,
you might be familiar with XML.
Here is some.
Can anyone tell what this is?
Can you guys see it well enough
to tell what this is data of?
Oh, we've got it over there.
It's the Olympics.
This is what the Olympics
looks like on the back end.
During busy competitions, we
can get 20 messages a second
from the Olympic data
stream, and yeah.
So, it's a large dataset.
Thankfully, in this
case, no one passes go.
No one collects $200
before they call the nerds.
Huge amounts of the Times
Olympics coverage is powered
by two news nerds sitting in a
press tent in the Olympic city.
My colleagues Michael Strickland and
Scott Blumenthal were there in Rio.
They gave me a little
rundown of how that went.
Our team keeps an, in fact,
our team keeps a collection
of Olympic mascots, the little
dolls, because the Olympics are
such a huge part of the
data work that we do.
So, what do we do?
We power graphics.
We get reporters the
most accurate information
in times and we answer questions.
So, if you enjoy watching the New
York Times cover the Olympics,
if you enjoy things
like split times,
if you want to see
those races that get run
in real time, and things like that.
That's all thanks to
this data stream.
In fact, my colleague Michael just
spent a week, like two weeks ago,
in South Korea starting to prepare
for next year's winter Olympics.
The news nerds from around the
world whose organizations cover the
Olympic feeds are actually
required to participate
in massive testing exercises
as part of their data contract
with the games that start
nearly a year in advance.
So, yes. If you enjoy watching this
kind of coverage, thank a news nerd.
Anyway, this is actually one of
my favorite stories from Rio.
I know it's not as exciting as
Katie Ledecky winning by 97 seconds
or whatever it was, but what I
like about this is that it was,
it's a narrative story
that came out of the data.
So, one of the reasons
this story came about is
because my colleague
Scott Blumenthal
who is a software engineer is
also a huge boxing enthusiast
and boxes himself.
So, he has been, he had his eye
on boxing from the beginning,
and he noticed, he was talking with
a reporter who was working on it.
And, they noticed that there
had been, there was some scandal
about competitors who were
worried that judges were biased.
And, they wanted to take a
little bit of a look at that.
They wanted to know, like,
what are we seeing or whatever,
and when they started looking, they
realized that there were some judges
who just disappeared
from competition.
Because judges are in that dataset.
The judge of every match.
There were judges who judged at the
beginning, and then stopped judging.
And, there was no clear reason.
They didn't, they weren't, like,
their ratings weren't
bad or whatever.
They just, they just disappeared.
And so, they were able to use
the data to find the story
that the judges were just gone.
They were dismissed,
but it was secret.
Let me tell you.
There we go.
Let me tell you another story.
Once upon a time, the
open government data was
in an adversarial format.
Uh-oh. Heard some laughing there.
As you, as you may be
aware, we had a major event
in Washington this January.
It was a Presidential Inauguration.
Unfortunately, after every
party comes the bill.
The cost of a Presidential
Inauguration is covered
by fundraising from the
Presidential Inaugural Committee,
and they have to release
a list of donors
to the Federal Election Commission.
Here's what it looked like.
What they did is they took this
report, and they delivered it
on paper to the Federal
Election Commission.
Someone knocked on the door of 990
E Street and, or 999 I think it is,
and handed it to the
Federal Elections Commission.
I just want to point out that this
was not how they had to release it.
It's not in statute that they
have to release it in paper.
The last of them released
them online,
and it's not like they typed
this out on a typewriter
and that was the only
way they could do it.
This is software.
They just chose to hit
the "print" button instead
of hitting the "send to FEC" button.
Yes. So, it was not
machine-readable data.
So, basically, the very next
call was, "Find me a nerd!"
Unfortunately, the sad story here is
that the news nerds aren't actually
that much help in this situation.
If the data is pretty badly
locked up, and we knew it.
But, what did we do?
We combined our nerd powers.
This is a repository from an editor
at the Washington Post
named Steven Rich.
He started manually cleaning
this filing in public.
Pretty quickly, he had
collaborations from reporters,
or from news nerds of various
sorts, a variety of organizations.
I'm up there, you can see,
and a few other folks.
So, in the end, we
had five different,
five different organizations
contributing
to this kind of information.
Another fun fact about this day
is that I saw that this filing was
out as I was eating my breakfast,
and the next thing I remember
it was 4:00 in the afternoon
and I was sitting on my sofa
in my pajamas still manually
entering these things.
So, it was a long day.
Despite the collaboration, the
news organizations wrote their
own stories.
It's not like we wrote one story,
but the background data was,
was in some ways collaboratively
managed.
The saddest news, in some ways for
the news nerds, is that by doing all
of this work, we helped reporters
discover that there were some issues
with the filing and a few, just a
few errors in the way it was filed.
So, that means they had
to file an amended report.
What did that mean?
Another one of those paper filings
came out about three months later
that we all had to dig into again.
They didn't file that one
electronically either,
as you can probably guess.
So, let me tell you another story.
Once upon a time, the
structured data was hiding.
Perhaps you've heard of this guy.
He's, like, kind of famous I
guess these days, especially maybe
in this kind of a location.
He wrote a play about
some guy named Hamilton.
Apparently, people really liked it.
They liked it so much that they
bought, that tickets are now going
for thousands of dollars.
I just want to point out
that on this thing it looks
like it says two tickets
because that's the
smallest number you can buy.
But, this is actually
the price for one ticket.
They would double it if
I bought two of them.
So, this is how you buy a ticket
for "Hamilton" I guess these days.
One of the major problems, one of
the reasons that the tickets are
so expensive is the resale market.
And people in New York,
understandably,
at the New York times,
we're really interested
in how this market was working and
what was happening and how resale,
resale companies were using
bots to buy up these tickets
and then sell them again.
So, they thought, if only we could
monitor how dates are selling
out and what the costs are.
I bet you'll never guess
what's coming next.
Yes, they called in the nerds.
In this case, it was
my colleague Tiff Fur,
and she basically wrote
a ticket buying bot.
But, instead of buying tickets,
all it did was look at the prices
and whether things were sold out.
So, it turns out a lot of people
at the Times were interested
in this data, potentially given
our proximity to Broadway there.
So, by recording this
ephemeral data,
Tiff was able to put together
a full structured dataset
that helped reporters understand
the scale of scalping on Broadway
for a variety of stories
they were telling.
So, this is what, what they think
Hamilton scalpers are making
in these ticket sales.
So, how am I doing on time?
Five minutes.
Okay. I'm going to add one more
story that I don't have slides
for because it's particularly
relevant today.
So, one recent situation where we
really wanted to get some data was
that the House of Representatives,
our neighbors right
across the street, were
voting on a healthcare bill.
That's going to happen again today.
The Senate gets to vote.
Unfortunately, it's quite hard
to get the data out of the House
and the Senate quickly because a
lot of it is being recorded by hand
by the clerk of the chamber.
So, what we ended up doing in the
House and what we will probably end
up doing in the Senate this
afternoon, I apologize if I have
to leave early to do this, is
have people actually sitting
in the chamber and quickly
writing by hand and doing things
like run out, take a
photograph, send it to someone
in New York who's going to
transcribe it, and run back in.
We are literally, manually
entering data and sending it back
and transcribing it and
making it electronic that way.
In some cases, that's the fastest
way to do it, and it works very well
for us in getting House votes live.
Some people have said, "Why
do you need to do that?
The data's going to be
available in 40 minutes, maybe."
One thing that you can't get from
that data, especially in the House,
is when people change their votes,
which is actually a pretty
common strategy in the House.
Sometimes, it's accidental.
The way you vote in the House.
I learned a lot about how
you vote in order to do this,
in our bodies of representation.
In the House, what you do is you
slide a little card into a machine,
and then you hit, I
guess there's a big yes
and no button, and
you hit the button.
So, people just hit
the wrong button.
There was a little
scandal a little while ago
about people letting
their kids vote for them,
which I think was causing
a few more of these errors.
But, so, that's how they do it.
If they vote incorrectly, they
can go and change their vote back,
and there's some though that
people might vote strategically.
They might say no, or they might
say yes and then if they don't,
if they're not really needed in
the final count, they might change.
So, by recording the
votes in real time,
we were able to get
that information out.
It was hard to do.
We needed five people in
the chamber to do the House.
Thankfully, the Senate's
a little smaller.
We're hoping to be able to get
by with a few fewer people.
So, like, every good
story, I'm going to end
with a "happily ever after".
Just the New York Times, we have
more programmers in the newsroom
than any other news
organization, and we do graphics
and digital storytelling.
And, we do creative news
presentation, but we also work
with data for nearly every
definition of the word data.
So, yeah. I'm ending this the
way good stories all end with a
"happily ever after", with
some very small exceptions.
So, thanks to my colleagues who
walked me through some of the work
that they did on data stories
so that I could share a more
wider perspective, and yeah.
That's all I got.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.